My name is Jie Qi. I'm a Berkman Fellow
this year and I'm also the co-founder
and creative director of Chibitronics,
which is an educational hardware company.
I'm really excited about exploring open
innovation, specifically around patents,
and how we can hack the patent system to
support sharing of inventions, rather
than closing it off. The reason I
care deeply about this is because as a
maker, and an entrepreneur, and kind of an
individual that's not a giant company,
I'm interested in exploring alternative
ways to create and make an impact with
my inventions. For example, one of
the inventions that I created as part of
my PhD research is this idea of using
stickers that are also electronics and
the idea is we took flexible printed
circuit boards which we find in our cell
phones or laptops or whatever, and we
added conductive glue to the bottom of
them, such that when you take the sticker,
which is a circuit board, and stick it
down to like a conductive ink or
conductive tape, you actually build
circuits, but it feels like you're
playing with stickers and tape and pens,
and that is kind of a creative, crafty
way to learn electronics. Technology is
very powerful right, it's a tool which
means it can do wonderful things, it
can do scary things. It itself is not bad.
However, with the many forces that
are at play in the world I can see
people or institutions with means
getting control of these technologies
and using them in a negative way that
perhaps the original inventors didn't
imagine or perhaps none of us have ever
imagined. What I'm excited about,
as someone who creates technology and
teaches people electronics and
programming, is that it is extremely
powerful and it allows you to take the
things that are in your imagination and
make them real. As an educator, when I see
people learn something new and create
something that they might not have
imagined they could, it's extremely
empowering and for me technology is a
way to make you see that the impossible
is possible and you can make with it.